there are a lot of misconceptions around
the postpartum period the idea that
motherhood should look perfect that it's
easy that it's normal to feel elated and
happy and not normal to feel sadness and
guilt it is a real struggle it's not
like social media depicts being a group
allows those moms to express what's
really going on in their lives
[Music]
Emerson is my two and a half year old
son and he is a very outgoing and bubbly
little boy he never stops yeah we might
be able to get him to take a short nap
they're not very helpful but very rarely
[Music]
the first few days of a Mersenne I think
actually went pretty smoothly things
started to kind of shift around the time
that Emerson was about two to three
weeks old
breastfeeding he wanted to eat every
hour to two hours and I was not going
back to sleep at one point I was awake
for approximately six days I was a
zombie I could barely function and I
just felt like a complete failure as a
mom my brain would go into that mindset
of I'm done I want to be dead
like everybody would have been better
off without me this was Emerson's first
fall festival and we'd attempted to go
earlier in the day but um I was just
having a horrible day I have you know a
good smile on my face but I was
miserable my husband Bill had done some
research and found the dignity health
pregnancy and postpartum support group
[Music]
going to that Wednesday support group
helped me understand and know that I
wasn't alone all right so let's go ahead
and get started I thought today we would
talk about how you've grown since the
first time you came as a mother who has
experienced a perinatal mood and anxiety
disorder I have a more personal
connection to these moms I know what
they have experienced people had told me
that I don't know what to do know I
still don't know what to do with her
talking about it is an essential part of
the healing process as soon as one mom
shares hopefully as we keep coming like
it's going to get better you can almost
see the tensions decrease that's a sense
of validation for the new moms who were
feeling guilty and beating themselves up
about how they were feeling just getting
out of bed was hard it was weeks that I
couldn't do laundry or dishes and I was
I'm home all day like what am i lacking
what would you say to them what advice
would you give I am awful at asking for
help even today I can say I'm really bad
at it but that's one thing I had to
immediately learn how to do I wouldn't
be alive if I didn't have help gia is
probably a lifesaver
there are very few people that have
probably stuck through the whole process
I was lucky that that first day I was
the only person that showed up until
towards the end to even imagine the road
that was ahead at that point it's kind
of scary because of her I was able to
stay here and be a mom to my kids and a
wife to my husband you supported me and
having another kid and so many people
told me not however which I would regret
today because I loved her so much and
had a such a different experience
this is Rockland she was born December
15th of 2018 and she is that missing
piece to our puzzle as a family I share
my story even though it's hard because
even if it helps one mom get the help
that they need that's really all that
matters
there's often something that we say to
moms that helps remind them that they're
gonna make it through this and that is
you are not alone there is help and you
can be well
you